newly released video features grisly
details of the South Carolina man's
murders of seven people tod collapse
confession revives the cold case and
explains how he kept a woman in
captivity for two months in a storage
locker david beg no has been following
the story for 48 hours and takes us back
to the scene of the crime the crime
scene was dark and unimaginable a young
woman with a chain around her neck kept
as a sex slave inside of an isolated
storage container here's this girl
chained up like a dog in the back of a
container did I just step into Hollywood
on a movie set this bizarre and
frightening story began Labor Day
weekend 2016 30 year-old Kayla brown and
her 32 year old boyfriend Charles David
Carver went missing near Spartanburg
South Carolina do you know where you
buddy is Kayla and Charlie had been
doing some cleanup work for Todd Cola he
was a local realtor who was held in high
esteem even by the sheriff Chuck Wright
did his job super good do you want to
buy a house to see someone you to call
well heck yeah I would but Cole up a
registered sex offender for a rape he
had committed as a teenager was living a
double life after her rescue Kayla was
rushed from the scene into an ambulance
there she began talking about her
two-month imprisonment at the hands of
Todd :
what didn't Todd do while you were there
there
[Music]
it's okay to cry
you've been through
Cayla survived her ordeal but seven
others who encountered Todd Cola did not
and in hours of candid confessions he
detailed those murders for police toys
my god the chest okay he dropped forward
I went around him and put another one to
respond all these confessions of a
serial killers journey into darkness
sometimes border on the surreal my golf
game is weak games fall I wonder what a
mother says to a son after he tells her
I killed seven people
oh and she experiences heart that she's
never experienced in earth or life
the inhumanity of people we were talking
is just chilling talks that but David's
report is part of a double feature of 48
hours which starts tomorrow night it
begins with the accidental husband
that's at 9:00 8:00 central and you can
watch serial confessions at 10:00 9:00
central right here on CBS